hey guys I'm Jess and you're watching me
talk about video games on the internet
and maybe hitting that subscribe button
if you liked today's show and I me know
how you go us up today Ubisoft is
opening two new studios in Europe one of
which is already set to start work on
something new the first studio is based
in Berlin and we'll work closely with
the Ubisoft owned Blue Byte on a quote
unannounced triple-a project you may
have already heard of blue bite through
their work on for honor and Rainbow six
siege or anno 2205 which they made
themselves UB is also currently working
on a new assassin's creed game which
according to the publisher will be out
when it's ready the newly created
Ubisoft Bordeaux studio will operate out
of southwest France and is going to
assist the companies are the French
studios I assume while they aren't
living it up drinking wine you B's
French studios are responsible for games
like Ghost Recon wildlands state and
just dense 2017 Rainbow six siege was
updated today and here's what that means
for those of you still playing the
latest update to the multiplayer
tactical shooter makes several changes
and fixes to operators most notably
while using the Russian snapper glass
you'll now have an easier time figuring
out if a shot is a hit or a mess after
the addition of a thermal sight in the
last midseason update this new update
emphasizes blood splatter after
successful hit and reduces the blur
around highlighted enemies echoes yokai
drone perhaps controlled with some kind
of yokai watch can now target any part
of an enemy's body in order to trigger
it's disorienting burst effect on the
debuff side shield operator montagne has
had the hipfire spread while using his
revolver increased especially at mid to
long ranges unfortunately a fixed for
the bug that causes habana swore
breaching pellets to detonate at
seemingly random times is not part of
this update after investigating Ubisoft
found that the only way to resolve the
issues is to rebuild the entire back end
design off the bonds gadget aiming to
have the issue fixed as part of year to
season two finally I've got some good
news and some bad news so which do you
want to hear first this isn't gonna work
i'm just going to give you the bad news
a Nintendo spokesperson informed
Eurogamer that the many NES classic
edition has been discontinued globally
so if you didn't manage to get one you
might be out of luck don't get too down
trodden though because alongside that
news comes room is that Nintendo is
working on a mini version of its SNES
console Eurogamer is reporting that the
snap plastic as it's expected to be
named will launch in time for Christmas
this year the report indicates that the
in-development device is a big reason
why the NES classic has been
discontinued despite its popularity
gamespot contacted Nintendo for
confirmation but they have refused to
comment on the rumors so we'll just have
to wait and see on this one that's
everything we've got for you today so do
let me know what you cared about down in
that comment box Hector gamespot for all
the latest news and features and I will
see you again tomorrow